so now we're ready to put together the
facts the GCD is a linear combination to
prove two cool results one fun the other
important and serious let's begin with a
die hard example so we looked at the die
hard state machine and we figured out
the behavior of it with jugs of size
three and five gallons and also with
jugs of size three and six gallons let's
look at the general case now suppose
that I have
jugs of a gallons and B gallons with a
and B are positive integers now when we
looked at the state machine we figured
out that under the die hard rules the
number of gallons in each bucket at any
stage is a linear combination of the
bucket sizes so at any point that in
after us any sequence of moves of
diehard moves in each bucket there will
be a linear combination of a and B now
the point is that linear combinations of
a and B are the same as multiples of the
GCD the reason is that the GCD is a
divisor of a and B of course it's a
common divisor and therefore it divides
any linear combination of a and B so any
linear combination of a and B is a
multiple of the GCD and the GCD is
itself a linear combination so linear
combinations of a and B are the same as
multiples of GCD so that gives us a
pretty good understanding of what the
amounts that we can get in the various
buckets are we can only get multiples of
G CDs but in fact you can get any
multiple of the GCD of a and B into a
bucket providing it will fit in the
bucket that's the same as saying that
you can get any linear combination
amount of a and B into a bucket if
there's room for it in the bucket so
let's see how to do that so suppose that
I have a linear combination of a and B
si plus TB that will fit in bucket B
mean
it's greater than equal to zero and it's
less than B so it's an it's a number of
gallons that could fit into bucket B how
do I get that amount into bucket B and
here's how we can assume that s is
positive we've already seen that we can
arrange that to be the case and so what
I want what we're going to do is repeat
the following procedure s times I'm
gonna fill up bucket a and pour it into
bucket B whenever B gets full fill
filled up I'll just dump it so that it's
empty and I can keep filling a bucket a
and pouring it into bucket B and I
repeat that s times now when I do that
the total number of times that I filled
bucket a is s times so the total amount
of water that I have taken from the
faucet or from the fountain is s times a
and I've poured it into B and then dump
it leaving only some amount that's in B
that's less than base so the amount
that's left after pouring in SI gallons
and dumping out what won't fit I'm left
with some amount that's non-negative and
less than B in bucket be okay now the
point is that the number of emptying of
bucket bay must be exactly Tay which is
why the amount of of water that's left
in bucket B is si minus TB and the
reason why it has to be minus T is that
if I've got si there if I had more than
T emptying 's I would have had bucket B
go negative it just isn't enough room
for it and if I had fewer than T
emptying then the bucket would have an
amount larger than B in it so the only
possible number of emptying of B is -
hey remember T is negative so minus T is
a positive number and that means that I
put in Si and taken out TB and I'm left
with exactly the linear combination si
minus TB so in fact there's no need to
count because you don't need to know
what Si and P what s and T are because
you can just knowing that you can get
any desired amount that's a limb that's
a multiple of the GCD into bucket B you
just keep doing this process until you
get the amount that you want so you fill
bucket a you pour it in to be that when
B fills you empty it
you just keep track of how much how many
gallons there are and bucket B and you
keep going until you get the amount that
you want and then you're done